My next guest is a talented comedian
who has both a critically
acclaimed half hour special
and album to rename already
our long awaited debut.
Our Special is called Girl Daddy.
It's on HBO max.
Please welcome Beth Stelling.
Hello Beth.
Hello.
And a cheers to your special,
Cheers.
all right
You drink special I'm
drinking the ginger buck.
What do you got in your...
What's it called?
I'm having the...
Its called the Margarita?
Yeah.
Out of a boot.
And we need these are branded drinks
I need to say right to
the camera Margarita boot
it take it to the max.
And if you can make a
red sound like an engine.
Okay, Margarita take it to the max.
Great. You sounded hammered and its..
I'm I hired/
It's perfect, it's exactly
what we were looking for,
we love it.
The "Girl Daddy" we're here
to talk about your special.
Yeah we are,
In this catchy interview,
welcome, why call it Girl Daddy?
I feel like I know a little bit
just from watching the special.
Yeah, I've been called a
female comics so many times
that if I have kids, I'm only
answering the Girl Daddy.
Its the only thing I'll answer too.
Yeah, that was out of our
way to feminize these titles.
Yes, then I'm gonna be,
it originated actually
from my nephew.
It's something that he called my sister.
His girl daddy?
Yeah, he's like, you're my girl daddy.
And you're like, that's mine.
And this kid gets no money.
Yeah, and I'm like, Look,
I can't live my life
without mining it for material so...
Yeah, what is the true thing that happens
is like I notice how often
the show doesn't even clear things up
when they bring some
up as a female comedian
if anything it brings the
show to a grinding halt
as the show goes stumbles all over
the "Yes Jimmy oh we have to catch out
watch out for those
raiders, all right, next go,
oh, God!"
We got a female.
"Girls behave yourself."
"Women get out of the room."
"Don't want your cycles to link up
we got a female comic
coming to the stage."
Like there's so baffle that
someone with different parts
is gonna do the same job as them.
It's kind of one of those things
where I get I don't know what to say like,
we have to maybe stop talking about it.
Like, how are we still
having the conversation?
Like why would I still be
getting asked the question?
"What's it like being a female comic?"
I feel like we're self
perpetuating at this point.
Yeah, sorry this is getting serious
I'm I looking for some real quick bites.
Yeah it's absolutely you
have to think about it
because it is asked in interviews,
and sometimes the only way
to get to these articles
is I comment on what it's
like being a female comedian.
Right, and it's like,
we've been freaking
doing it for a long time.
When I was younger, I used
to answer the question like,
it's great. It's an advantage.
I stand out on the lineup,
(mimicking)
And then lately,
I've heard from some other females comics
that they don't appreciate that
and that we should be talking about
that it's more difficult or whatever it is
or the problems with it.
And it's like, I don't
know what it'll stop
females have been killing.
Maybe I should have shut my
door before this interview.
I know you have movers coming in
you're being evicted from your apartment.
'Cause you're a comedian in 2020.
So, you're being currently evicted.
Also, congrats on this special.
Thank you so much.
But the movers are gonna
be stalling your furniture
at the house
Yeah, well we're doing this
interview to promote Special
A lot of things are being repoed for me.
Yeah, is there something else with you,
no longer afford it.
happening?
Should I shut my front door?
The front door?
Yeah, shut the front door.
(laughing loudly)
Is this a bit "Shut the front door."
Okay.
Yeah.
It's being checked.
If your Max is just like
HBO but it's very clean.
(laughing loudly)
Its HBO for Christians so..
wait a minute.
A lot of succession is heavily edited.
Somebody who was like when are we gonna
get a family friendly HBO special?
It's like, is that what they're known for?
The HBO special genre family friends.
Yeah.
Well, this specials for the hoes,
and the dirty dogs out there.
This is a dirty special folks.
I'm thankful I got it in Moses,
I would be freaking out if I were you.
I'm sorry, I'm even
drawing attention to it.
That's very fair, guess we
were talking about that earlier
where we have yet to tape our specials.
And it's like, I don't
know how we're gonna do it.
I'd much rather be in your position.
I was listening to sets before this
to remember what life was before.
Yeah to remember what standard was.
And because I knew we were gonna talk
about the special but I do
feel so disconnected from it,
but it gave me the memory like we are
so lucky to do our jobs
and be what they are.
And I don't know if I really
was thinking of it that way.
But I'm listening and I'm
like, this hour especially.
I worked really hard
to even have the stage
be close to the audience.
I'm very connected to the audience.
I'm touching them at
times, not like a lot.
But you put your fingers
in people's mouths,
it was really weird.
(laughing loudly)
I won't say super spreader
but you've recorded this February.
(laughing)
Way before the shutdown, and also, yeah,
we'll just finish this
website, it is insane.
Well my specials is not gonna work.
It's all talking about
how come constants are
so crowded these days.
(laughing)
We're always getting bumped.
But you're special, it's very
connected with the crowd.
You have a great stage setup
where it's like a comedy club where people
are on each side of you.
You're ready to even talk to the audience.
I do, I have to pick in
the first four minutes
I have to pick someone that's gonna kinda
stay with me throughout
this special, a man.
I thought in this particular special
that man is Jeremy
but I had many men throughout
the tour that helped me.
Wow.
But I had to make that choice within like,
I come out I'm looking
at, you see your crowd.
You're looking at him.
You're looking for the right guy to pick
you almost have to pick someone
who's not frightfully shy.
But he looks gentler and a teeny shy
because you want them to know
that they are gonna be in good hands
somebody who will hate sitting up front
'cause I think there could
be destroyed, not my goal.
At your show absolutely, look at this guy,
look at your eye brows, too sick my man.
Were you sick right before?
Oh my gosh,
I think I got sick in Chicago in January.
I must have picked something up.
I was traveling and touring,
like three months straight in preparation.
And I got sick in January..
Which is a dangerous time.
Yeah.
Looks like saying,
I was just kicking around Iraq in 2004.
The work that's such a loaded answer.
We were sick in January.
Yeah.
A super splatter.
Exactly.
And it felt like I couldn't get rid of it.
And so of course, I don't
wanna be one of those people
who's like I already had it,
but I'm telling you I got sick in January.
I couldn't shake it.
I feel like I'm gonna get it.
(laughs)
(machine beeps)
Oh my god!
101.
Oh no.
(machine beeps)
96 you're clear cheers
to our two drink minimum.
Nice, thank you, 96 its weird.
This is a facial testing this
is better than the testing
that we already have.
Maybe it's stress and travel
of touring leading up to it.
And but I do like I like
to do vocal warm ups.
I come from a musical
family, and so I was..
Oh, your mom is a music teacher, right?
That's right.
So we always did some
good classic warm ups.
Did you want me to do it for you?
Yes, please.
I need some vocal warm ups.
(grunting)
♪ Mommy made me mash mayanams ♪
(mimicking)
That was pretty good,
♪ Daddy made me cry myself to sleep, ♪
You seem, this are official words?
Yeah, this I took some liberties.
♪ sisters made me feel real and secure ♪
(mimicking)
♪ Sisters made me feel really secure. ♪
Most of the time is
like unique New Yorker.
The last one will really
I think appeal to you.
♪ The first time I had
sex was with a doll. ♪
♪ First time I had sex was with doll. ♪
Doll
Very personal
to me and to you.
(laughing loudly)
Are these not universal?
I've never heard them
they sound legit, though
and take it from the special
you have inanimate objects.
So, dolls coming from real life.
Sometimes I would cheat on the couch
with the end of the bathtub.
I was a bit of a humper
I guess here and there.
It's something I've been open about
Because it was ever described to you.
No, I think yes.
I don't know if you were ever taught.
It depends on how your
parents taught you sexuality
I know some parents discuss masturbation
with their kids.
I remember in my special,
you'll remember that
we had a health teacher
that talked about teaching
their sons how to masturbate,
which I thought was illegal.
But if I had been caught..
Never forget I used to cum after that,
Can you
(laughing)
Such a weird, mine was
like very religious parents
was very repressive.
It's never gonna get talked about.
So, I just got like pieces from TV
and then watch my own buddy was screaming
why were parents depressed about it?
Was your mom like, that's fine?
No, my mom never caught me.
I think if she caught
humping in the house,
maybe we'd have talked about it.
But,
Yeah.
Now she never made me feel
bad or guilt or anything.
It was less I think was just more of a
not totally discussed thing.
Then you should be doing certain things.
Yeah.
How's your mom feel about your stand up?
We had a discussion about this recently,
especially in regard to
sex and talking about it
cause when I first started,
I was very much like,
very aware of the
stereotypes of female comics
like that, unfortunately,
still exists 13 years later,
which are women all talking about sex,
and so I was like, I'm
not gonna write about sex.
I'm not gonna, repeat jokes,
and I won't sleep with any comics.
Those are my rules when
I first started at 22.
Yeah.
I kept those for a while.
But then I think you become a grown woman.
It's like, Well, why can't I
offer my perspective on this?
It doesn't have to be some sort of
exploitative graphic description of sex,
but I think it can only help to
have more people's perspective
on their experience.
And my mom looks at it like,
"Yeah, she doesn't love
but she calls it like body parts humor."
Like she doesn't love cussing,
she doesn't love parts.
I don't like when you talk about
your bathroom parts on stage.
(laughing loudly)
But I think she's also just like,
You're a grown woman and some
of this isn't gonna be for me.
All right cheers Beth.
Congratulations on the Special.
I admit it when I say it's really great.
I'd highly recommend
it, Girl Daddy, HBO max.
Thank you Beth for joining us, bye.
Bye baby.